- Welcome back everybody.
We're hanging out with
Hilary Duff, give it up.
(audience cheering)
So her show How I Met Your Father
is all about a woman
explaining to her son how she,
well met his father, it's in the title.
And because there are a
bunch of great father figures
in entertainment,
we thought now is a good
time for a game called
Like Father, Like Son
Can You Name the Other One?
♪ Like Father, Like Son ♪
♪ Can You Name the Other One ♪
- Oh, we got a jingle.
- Way to go, Jesse.
Oh heavenly Father, are you there?
Could you possibly host this game for us?
(angelic music)
- He's there.
- Well, of course I can,
Kelly, you like that entrance?
- I did.
- That was some
good stuff right there.
- I know Hilary, not all
shows have God, but we do.
- It's good to see you, Kelly.
Hilary, I'm a big fan.
I'm fan girling over here.
- Oh my God.
- I love Lizzie McGuire.
- Thanks.
(audience cheering)
Right back at you.
- Oh, I've seen every episode,
you know, the one where she tells her mom
she's buying school supplies,
but really she's getting her first bra?
That's my favorite.
I love that one.
- What in the world?
- We're throwing it way back.
- Way, way back.
- Way back, way back.
Okay, anyway, so here's
what's about to happen.
I'm gonna give you guys
a clue that includes
the name of a father or
son from a famous book,
movie or TV show.
- Okay.
- Now all you have to do.
- A book.
- That's right, a book.
- I know, it's the thing, you open it up,
it's got pages and all that.
(Kelly laughing)
Now all you have to do is buzz in
and name the other character
of the father son pair
and steals are allowed if
the other person is wrong.
- Oh.
- Okay.
- So that's how
that's gonna work.
I know, Kelly.
- I'm not confident.
- Watch out Kelly.
- I am not confident.
- Come on now, come on now.
Now Hilary, you gonna be
playing to win a cool prize
for everybody on the left
side of the audience.
There you go.
- I'm gonna try guys
- Let me hear you, okay.
(audience cheering)
Okay, pipe down, that's enough now.
And Kelly, you're playing
for everybody on the right.
- Where you at?
- Everybody on the right!
- That's what I'm talking about.
- There you go.
(audience cheering)
- Left side.
- I'm really, really sorry if we lose.
- Okay.
- Okay, you ready to play?
Here we go.
- Yes, okay.
- All right, here's
your first clue.
- Okay.
- This father, named
Marlin just kept swimming
halfway across the ocean.
- Oh, oh.
- Did you get it?
- Marlin, it's the little one.
It's, not Dory's the other one.
It's keep swimming.
(Kelly screaming)
- I'm watching you, audience.
- Nemo, Nemo!
- Oh!
- It is Nemo.
- Oh my gosh.
What in the world, I've seen
the movie a billion times.
Just swimming.
- That's right you got it, Kelly.
Here's your next clue.
George's son saw his parents' first kiss
when he went back to
1955 and played guitar
at The Enchantment Under the Sea dance.
What was the son's name?
- Oh, oh, that Marty McFly.
- Kelly you're crushing this.
(Kelly screaming)
- It was Marty McFly.
- You know Back To the Future.
- Yes, yes!
Yes!
- Kelly, you're crushing this.
- I am crushing it!
(Hilary laughing)
(audience cheering)
- I had no faith in me.
- A surprise to no one.
- Sorry left side.
(Kelly laughing)
- I'm so sorry.
Listen, you gonna pull it
out, girl, don't worry.
That's gonna happen,
it's gonna happen, okay.
You know, speaking of first kisses
that reminds me when Lizzie
kissed Ronnie the paper boy
to make Gordo jealous.
Gordo is such a dummy that Gordo.
Okay, here we go.
- We should switch this
game up to a Lizzie.
- I think he's gonna win.
- I'm so sorry about that.
- Yeah I think he's gonna win.
Oh, I'm so excited you're here.
I just love that show.
Okay, here we go.
- Okay.
- Next one.
This one is, let's see
this donut loving dad
often called his.
- Simpsons, Bart.
- No, now what, what was the dad's name?
- Oh, oh, Homer.
- It was Homer, I'm gonna give it you.
(audience cheering)
- I got you, I got you.
- Don't.
- You knew by Donut.
- I knew by donut.
- This next one is worth
- Okay.
- two points.
- Peter was a father who just
wanted to take his family
on a nice vacation for Christmas,
but he left his son home alone.
What was the son's name?
- Kevin McCallister.
- God.
- It was
(audience cheering)
Kevin McCallister.
- It was really, that was really quick.
She's quick on that one.
(fog horn blowing)
- Oh, and now it is time
for our final question.
- Okay.
We're tied.
- This one is worth
double the points.
Double the points.
- You came back, you came back.
- Okay, here we go.
His dad was tragically thrown
from a cliff by his uncle.
His name was Simba, what was his dad name?
- Oh, Mufasa.
(audience cheering)
- It was Mufasa, unbelievable.
- All right.
- So as always, it's my show,
so everyone's winning, so I don't care.
So what you're gonna win is
the KitchenAid Semi
Automatic Espresso Machine.
It's the first at home espresso machine
featuring dual smart temperature sensors
for perfect brewing.
And you're all gonna
get to enjoy espressos,
lattes and cappuccinos at home
because you're each getting one.
(audience cheering)
- That's so exciting!
Yes!
- And because Hilary won,
her photo will be hung
on The Chicks Wall of Champs.
(audience cheering)
It's a dumb wall.
Everybody be sure to watch new episodes
of How I Met Your Father
Tuesday's on the Hulu.